each year at commencement our university
recognizes an exceptional
individuals with honorary degrees these
degrees are the most significant
distinction conferred by the Yale
corporation the University's Board of
Trustees to signal pioneering
achievement in a field or conspicuous
and exemplary contribution to the common
good though we cannot adorn this year's
honorary degree recipients in their
academic hoods or applaud their
accomplishments as they stand on the
commencement stage we gather from our
computers phones and devices around the
world to recognize the ways in which
they have expanded our knowledge and
gifted us with their art song
scholarship and innovation today we
honor nine individuals who serve as
examples to our graduates and members of
the Yale community they encourage us to
aspire to excellence and to value those
elements of human character that they
embody creativity curiosity disciplined
integrity and a passion for public
service their association with the class
of 2020 also honors the students who
graduate today collectively they
represent the aspirations of Yale as an
institution it is now my distinct
pleasure to announce the 2020 honorary
degree recipients and to confer their
degrees for the degree of Doctor of Laws
to Rome Alan Cohen legal scholar
pioneering scholar of Chinese law you
have taught and mentored countless
others in a field you helped establish
in this country a courageous voice for
those whose voices have been silenced
you defend human rights around the globe
bold trailblazer and advocate for using
your many talents to create a more just
world we are
proud to present you with your third
Yale degree Doctor of Laws for the
degree of Doctor of music Herbie Hancock
musician and composer chameleon of
modern jazz you have shown us new
possibilities and encouraged us to
imagine a better world by experimenting
with science and sound
you let your talent take you and us to
new places breaking down barriers
between genres and creating chords of
peace that connect humanity Wonderful
Wizard and musical icon
Yale is delighted to confer on you this
Doctor of Music degree
for the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters Christiana Figueres public
servant your diplomacy has brought
people and nations together to address
one of the most important issues of our
time climate change building bridges
instead of borders
you've led countries to action helping
forge international Accords to ensure
the health and survival future
generations on this planet global
citizen skilled leader yell is honored
to award you this Doctor of Humane
Letters degree for the degree of Doctor
of Engineering and Technology
Michael I Jordan computer scientist
facing an uncertain and complex world
you harness the power of human and
machine learning to solve daunting
problems by bridging disciplines and
following your curiosity you have made
possible what was once only imagined
Explorer of new domains champion of big
ideas and recognition of the doors who
have opened and the networks who have
built we proudly bestow on you this
doctor of Engineering and Technology
degree for the degree of Doctor of Fine
Arts Ming Jolie theatrical set designer
you have set the world on stage and your
influence circles the globe your
classroom is legendary with insight and
humility
you inspired thousands of Yale students
to create new vistas of art and meaning
generous teacher visionary artists for
helping a see feel and understand the
great drama of human life anew we're
delighted to confer on you this Doctor
of Fine Arts degree for the degree of
Doctor of
science savant a pabo evolutionary
geneticist from bone fragments thousands
of years old you show us what has
endured and what has been lost from
ancient times to the present day
applying the latest science to age-old
questions you have revealed secrets
about the prehistoric world discovered
previously unknown species and invented
a new field of study passionate
scientist for opening a window onto our
ancestors and ourselves Yale is
privileged to confer on you this Doctor
of Science degree for the degree of
doctor of music Renee Fleming soprano
you have shared your extraordinary voice
on the world's greatest stages thrilling
audiences with your repertoire and range
transcending styles and traditions you
champion the importance of music for our
health
minds and communities soaring soprano
lyrical ambassador of the Arts for
helping us here all the octaves of life
more clearly we are honored to present
you with this Doctor of Music degree for
the degree of doctor of Medical Sciences
Jim Allison immunologist your
discoveries have transformed the science
of cancer treatment opening up new
frontiers in medicine by unleashing the
power of t-cells you enlisted the body's
own immune system to combat this
terrible disease and your research has
restored health and hope to patients
laureate and lifeline in honor of the
futures you have made possible with
gratefully bestow on you
this doctor of Medical Sciences degree
and for the degree of Doctor of Letters
Paula Vogel playwright and educator
while waltzing or driving dying or
loving your characters connect with
audiences and bring urgent issues out of
the shadows a devoted teacher you foster
the future of theater helping young
playwrights find their voices and refine
their craft an appreciation for your
brave artistry and spirited mentorship
Yale is proud to award you this Doctor
of Letters degree
I send my warm congratulations to all of
you the entire university joins me in
applauding your accomplishments welcome
to the class of 2020